- Rachel, is it true that you also,
I know cause the WWE that's
right, you wrestled, right?
- I did in high school.
Not, not--
- This is amazing,
this my favorite thing.
This is my favorite thing
I've learned about you
'cause we were gonna have them on here
and then they're like,
actually Rachel is a wrestler
and I was like, what?
- That's amazing.
- You wrestled in high school?
- I, oh yeah, it's pretty tragic,
that is a lot of look.
- That is amazing.
Well, maybe we can bring
out those moves again.
- Wait,
were there a lot of girls where
you're from that wrestled?
- No, I was the only girl on our team.
No, sorry, there was one
girl who was older than me
on varsity while I was on
in the, you know, in the,
in the little leagues
and it was, I mean, it was amazing.
It was a blast.
I had so many friends who were doing it.
That was, that was kind of the,
the thinking behind it,
but I wasn't great,
but I loved it.
- That's awesome.
- So you,
so you mainly wrestled then guys.
- Yeah, but I mean, you know,
it's done by weight class,
so it didn't feel, you know,
that's the gift of
wrestling is it feels like
the only thing that separates you
is what you're better at than someone else
and what they're better at than you,
but you weigh the same
and that puts you on a pretty
even playing field, I think.
- Yeah.
- Totally.
- I love that.
- That's so cool.
- Have you ever pulled
a move on your partner?
Have you just like pulled,
did you just lay 'em out?
Like I think that would be really cool.
- There's still time.
- Yeah.
- There is still time.
- I'm just, I have great ideas Rachel,
so I'm just throwing it out there.
You're welcome.
- I love it.